- Y'all had fun at the wrap party, though.
What's happenin'?
What's happenin' there?
I saw,
I saw, well one, I saw a photo
and I saw some footage we're gonna get to.
- Well, we had a
- What was happening?
- great wrap party, and then
they pulled us up on stage
for karaoke and we were singing
some New Kids on the Block
because who doesn't?
- Because why not?
- I'm a '90s girl.
- 'Cause why not?
- Okay.
And then they surprised us
and we sang the Fuller House theme song
'cause everyone knows it
and that was really fun.
- Oh my gosh.
- And then--
- I would've totally
sang along.
I know the whole thing.
- I kinda don't even know all the words,
most of them.
- See, I kinda do.
(laughter)
You had an unexpected
audience, I hear, with karaoke.
- Okay, so the embarrassing part
is that Karaoke Candace
doesn't come out very often.
It's like once in a while.
- Why?
Karoke's so fun.
- Because...
I know, but I don't do that
publicly very often, okay?
- [Kelly] Look at you!
You're going!
(audience cheers)
- Okay, so, okay.
(audience claps)
That as me rapping Sir
Mix-a-Lot, "Baby Got Back."
- Oh!
- Yes!
Yes!
So wait, what was the
unexpected audience?
- So the unexpected part
was that I got a message the next morning
from Jodie Sweetin.
She texted me a video message
and she was like, hey Candace, I'm outside
and I bet you didn't know,
but your video right now
is being broadcast to all
of Hollywood & Highland.
Now, for those of you
that don't know
- They have like pins,
you were at that,
what is that bowling alley?
- Lucky Strikes.
- Lucky Strikes, that's what it is,
yeah.
- bowling alley.
And Hollywood & Highland
is like Times Square.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- So my karaoke version of "Baby Got Back"
was all, like, for everyone to see.
- You were full-on
twerking on the camera.
- I was mortified.
No, not twerking, Kelly.
This mama doesn't twerk.
(Kelly stumbles)
But I was just--
- That was some version
of twerk.
- It was just a little, a little
booty shake.
- It looked good.
You did nice.
- That was just
a little booty shake.
- It was nice, it was nice.
So do you like karaoke?
- I love karaoke.
- 'Cause people always think
that singers are like over it,
but I love karaoke.
- I love karaoke,
but the weird, it's
weird if you're a singer
and you go in and you sing your own song.
You know what I mean?
- Yes.
- No, people ask you to do that
and you're like, "No."
- 'Cause then, then you just
look like an idiot.
- But I bet...
But do people ever go, like,
"Hey, that guy's pretty good.
"He sounds just like him."
(audience laughs)
- That happened.
- But like they don't get it.
- That happened to me once.
I was karaoking with Reba
and then she got up on
stage, we sang together.
Obviously, they recognized her,
but they kept going, "She
looks like Kelly Clarkson,"
and then Reba got on stage
and it was really awesome.
We had had some drinks.